you enjoy playing a prank on your
children yeah not obviously not the 18
month old because Addison it's easy
there's no Sun there is a side there's
no so I don't know I think I think she's
already at the point where she's yes you
could prank her now she's good she's a
smart one but Gus is fair game and has
been for a while he's got the best sense
of humor because I've tortured him his
whole life probably but he really is the
greatest kid in the history of the world
and you took a you took a little video
of you pranking your son and this is I
explain how it works you sort of
convince him how does the prank how
what's the setup to the well the setup
was I had just come back from Europe and
I think I had like a European coin of
some sort and I told him he could have
it if he could drop the coin from his
forehead into this funnel that I had put
in his waist it put it in the waistband
of his pants right right so I let him
have his eyes open and draw it a couple
times and he had it he was doing really
well and nailed it and and so then I was
like okay this is for all the marbles if
you're gonna get this coin you have to
do it now with your eyes closed
and he was like okay dad I'm on my god I
think we get the footage we'll tell it
where a role of David keep your head
back close eyes closed eyes closed
wait are you filming
[Applause]
Wow
years ago Suns reaction is priceless but
I like the dogs like what are you gonna
do yeah that's my kid and the dog seen
it before I seen it all before that was
ran away that was like three years ago
we still laugh about